and my question is yeah how do i hustle
and stop being a [ __ ] an attack I want
to be where you are I've got what's
blocking you some I don't know other
people's POV yes that's the one man but
how do I just I can I know I can be with
is it like parents is it who are the
other people it's society's family yeah
man
got to have that real talk especially
tougher for immigrants and [ __ ] like
that like you got to look on the [ __ ]
face and be like this is what I'm doing
I'm like [ __ ] you for judging me and you
know how hard that is some people you
could go to the ground and never be able
to do it but if you want the answer
that's the answer you know what I mean
you got to get there and honestly man
you just gotta get there like every day
in the same way Mike with my training
that was every day in my head like I
gotta fix this I gotta get my health
right I gotta get my health right I
gotta get my health right every day you
got to say I got to tell my dad I got to
tell my dad I got to tell my mom I've
had to tell my Brett like every day
until you finally break and you just get
it you find your opening like that I
don't figure that and just you got to
get poison out of your body you got to
get the poison out of your body you know
dude you know the craziest part is the
craziest part I've said this enough and
a couple people think God have taken me
up on it deep down you've seen the
movies that parent where that sibling
where that spouse normally respect you
more for doing it so you're worried
about respect and you're losing it
because they can taste the fear in your
face and then you go and do it and they
[ __ ] repeat what you wanted you got
by doing the actions it's gonna free you
up to do it
you can hit me up on email it's in crush
it if you need my help every day every
day every day the same way I wake up
every day a pretend my family died and
that's why I'm always happy
you need to pound yourself into I gotta
tell them today be like I gotta go do
this and the only reason I'm not is
because you're gonna judge me and you
got to tell me that you won't and if
they tell you that they will judge you
then at least you got it out and then
you go and then [ __ ] prove them wrong